right let's get more on the omnicron
variant now and find out more about
exactly what kind of threat it could
pose to us i'm now joined by professor
sir david spiegelholter who is a leading
statistician based at the university of
cambridge and the author of covid
by numbers um good morning professor
spiegel halter
good morning
what are the numbers telling us about
the risk
that we face from this new variant
it's um it's a very difficult situation
because we haven't got a lot of data yet
at all almost nothing from this country
about what the risks are um of south
africa there's data coming out showing
pretty strong evidence of increased risk
of transmission and no and
some evidence about people going to
hospital that it may actually be milder
but we haven't got enough data yet to be
able to say it doesn't look as if it's
you know really severe if you get it i
think that's about all we can say at the
moment
so at the moment your view is uh
keep calm and carry on to some extent
yeah we're at a very tricky time i mean
the the the policy has led to a very
delicate balancing act for months
essentially with high case rates and
what apparently seemed to be tolerable
hospitalizations
uh that have been coming down recently
and even deaths coming down but a very
strange situation where um
cases in young people are going up
especially in london cases and old
people are still coming down and that's
the booster effect
boosters have been we're being saved by
boosters essentially they are
extraordinarily effective and if you've
had you know double astrazeneca and then
pfizer you're more protected than you've
ever been right from the beginning right
from when you had the initial
vaccinations um i mean i know i
shouldn't sell a you know i'm a
statistician i collect data but i do
like stories as well and somebody was
tweeting out about their 93 year old
grandmother who was trip got covered but
she was triple backs and she just had a
runny nose i mean i know that's only one
person but we do know that they're
saving very large numbers of lives they
i think it's a real problem i mean first
of all you know there's a big
push now to get boosters out i'm not
quite sure why we're only doing that now
you know it was so clear that these are
the lifesavers we had to get them out
and
but last it's happening um but the
benefits have been very poorly
communicated and if you if your
hospitalization protected of your you
know um
protection against going to hospital has
dropped say from 97 to 91
well it doesn't sound very much does it
and topping that up well you know is
that very important but if you flip it
round and look at your vulnerability
your relative vulnerability has gone
from three percent to nine percent you
know the opposite the opposite to the 97
and 90 and 97 and the 91 then that means
your risk has gone up three times so
just that bit of waning has massively
increased your risk
and i think if things were being
communicated much more about that
and the fact that boosters
massively reduce your risk of
hospitalization and debt then uh the
take-up might be even
stronger well i'm i'm with you that
statos ought to be allowed to tell more
stories because uh uh statistics often
tell us the greatest stories but um one
story which i think we don't quite know
the end to is this um
even if we are still just dealing with
delta this winter
what do you estimate to be the bigger
risk
uh delta covid
or a flu
what should we be more worried about
well
to be honest flu is very low at the
moment not as low as last year it's
almost none last year at all but it is
actually very low at the moment because
we're still taking lots of protective
measures we're nothing we're not mixing
socially anything like as much as we
were have been normally in a normal
winter where flu might kill 10-20 000
people so actually i mean it's great
that everyone's been jabbed over my flu
jab but flu at the moment does not look
like the main risk um to over this
winter um you know apart from covid i
think the big risk over this winter even
before the nude variant came along was
just the standard risk almost at the nhs
overwinter which is the huge pressures
that are on it which we can see you know
and and that's only made worse by covet
cases
requiring more resources and of course
the huge backlog that's built up because
of the pandemic so um the flu is i don't
think is such an issue over this winter
what what do you make of the story
that's emerging this morning about the
um
proportion of covert beds that uh
are being occupied by those who are
unvaccinated and i guess there are a
couple of uh questions here but to start
with
is that really significant 90 percent of
the beds
allocated to covid which are 20 i think
of critical care uh beds uh
are occupied by people who are
unvaccinated is that really a big issue
or is it marginal
um that's not it's not true of
hospitalizations the majority of people
in hospital with kovid have been
vaccinated and that's exactly what we'd
expect when nearly everybody
who is vulnerable to um particularly
vulnerable to covet have been vaccinated
that's that's not saying the vaccines
don't work it's just saying they're not
perfect intensive care is different
because the people go into intense care
much younger than the standard a person
who um who's at risk with coved and goes
into hospital they're highly selected
and uh and in there the majority of beds
are unvaccinated um i
personally in my opinion is i think it's
very unfortunate indeed that these
people are not vaccinated and they might
they and their families might possibly
be regretting that that decision but um
they they uh they have to be treated
just like
someone who smokes is treated in
hospital like everybody else and so
there is a duty to treat them but i
think it's very unfortunate and that any
um you know
any effort to to increase the take of
the vaccines is valuable and of course
you know that's both to uh protect
people around you but also it is just to
protect yourself
looking at the history of these things
do you think that there's a point at
which you reach a sort of a ceiling uh
on the levels of vaccination and that
there is always going to be if you like
a recalcitrant minority that just won't
have it
absolutely you won't convince everybody
there'll always be some there'll always
be a small a small group of people and
um in a way they
you know to some extent they take
advantage of what the rest of the
community are doing um i uh so i i'm not
really um
you know i i don't comment on policy i
i think it'd be unfortunate perhaps if
there was um all the vaccinations made
mandatory though because it makes
martyrs out of people um and uh just
every effort should be done to get
people to volunteer to be vaccinated but
it won't cover everybody um no that
that's impossible and even if it did
even if we're all vaccinated this virus
is going to be circulating it's not
going to wipe out the virus we're not
going to reach that and so um in fact
although it would be great if more were
vaccinated that's not like it's not like
that's going to eliminate the epidemic
can we
talk about the government's uh steps
thus far looking back at what has been
done in previous waves we now have the
travel ban we have
you know exhortations to behave in a
common sensical way and so on
if
what we fear about omicron is true
is what's been done so far
enough to stop it
again i'm not going to say exactly what
should be done because i don't i'm not
an infectious disease expert i'm not
going to say i wouldn't dream of saying
what policy should be but as the
previous um interview he said um it's
best to be precautionary when we don't
there's so much we don't know i mean it
really looks like this overcrowded virus
is more
transmissible we don't know whether
that's because it's intrinsic property
of the virus that makes it more
transmissible or whether it's because it
can get around um you know the immunity
with people have got either from having
previous infections or from vaccinations
so and there's a you know wide range of
different combinations of those that
could still lead to more
transmissibility there's so much we
don't know and when we don't know it's
better to be safe than sorry now what
exactly what that means is another
matter and this is a terror just like
last year with the alpha variant this is
a terrible time for a variant to come
along
when it's probably the next two weeks
are probably some of the highest risk um
periods with a lot of indoor socializing
that we know is extremely high risk and
so um it's appalling timing i'm sure the
government would love
not to disrupt christmas
what happens after christmas of course
is another matter i mean the travel
travel restrictions at the moment are
only going to slow things up a little
bit possibly or you know to some extent
um but they're not going to stop it and
it's going to come in and um where you
obviously will do everyone will do their
best to stop it spreading but
um you know where the new year is quite
likely to see some quite um
a lot of challenges to face and as sage
has said that's yeah that could work
very well mean more stringent measures i
think i could mention working from home
which so far has not been recommended
but that is
known to be extremely effective at uh
halving the number of close contacts
people have and in the end it's how
close you know it's how many people
you're breathing over and i should say
if you people want to go into the
british medical journal we've just got a
nice interactive animation there where
you can click on a little image and show
i'm wearing a mask i'm singing i'm two
meters away the other person's not
wearing a mask what's the what's what's
my risk of transmitting the virus if
i've got it and you can change all these
things and see them
and see them wobbling around and what is
an effective measure and um and i think
that's quite informative it's certainly
actually changing my views of what i
perhaps i might do
well that sounds like a good sunday
afternoon alternative to playing
fortnight but just
quickly if i may ask you this um
you've probably got a better fix on than
most on the progress of these things
in reality
um have we just
got to abandon the notion that this
thing will go away
but accept that it will be endemic that
we are going to have to live with it uh
in the same way that we live with flu
um i again
i'm taking the judgment that other
people have made but uh yes it's not
going to go away i don't think there's
no way this could be eliminated and it's
going to be spreading around people have
suggested this omicron it's a you know
the sort of an endemic variant that
might just be you know we might just
have to this is one we might have to
live with for some time and um and we're
going to have to get used to it and that
will it could very well involve as
people said you know top up uh vaccines
um
uh
i don't know i i get very sad thought of
us you know having to have you know
changing our mode of socializing and
things like that and traveling um
so i it's unclear what that will mean in
terms of on our lives except
i think we're we will be vaccinating
getting boosters um
for the foreseeable future